at seven points on Saturday down in  Oklahoma here comes Whiteside with his  shot rebound horde out to Lillard free  the rebound and second shot  opportunities 1/2 minutes ago coming up  the American Express halftime report  what three from Great Bend one dribble  one dribble over half-court and I raise  he wasn't Bend Oregon was look at that  man oh man that was a beauty nice drive  here by Simons out to Lillard defense  got off track and that opens up the door  for Damian Lillard was a playmaker there  and that has been a change in direction  for him 40 points for Damian look they  double Willard  it's off to Anthony Simons wide open  three to fire Lillard  difference of two and a half seconds  game clock and shot clock know they're  working on Burke's dancing free up three  [Applause]